well the fact that we can print their
own money is ultimately gonna be our
undoing Peter Schiff knows a thing or
two about financial collapse having
predicted one in this country and also
having made a lot of money surfing the
vagaries of the international market
with euro pacific capital peter schiff
thanks for joining us thanks for having
me
we've been at zero interest rates now
for seven years anything that happens
for seven years does it not almost by
definition especially if it's an unusual
a historically unusual thing doesn't
that automatically create a bubble well
it has created a bubble and I think it's
an enormous bubble and in fact the
reason that interest rates have been at
zero for so long is because I think the
Fed is cognizant of this even though
they don't admit it publicly which is
why they're so reluctant to raise rates
you know even to a quarter of a percent
or a half a percent because this bubble
is just so big and if you can go back
and recognize how much damage alan
greenspan did by keeping rates at 1% for
about a year and a half and then slowly
raising them back up to five and a
quarter over you know year
year-and-a-half period right that's what
really inflated the housing bubble and
that led to the financial crisis of 2008
trying to resolve the malinvestments
that were the byproduct of that bad
monetary policy so think about how bad
that was and now imagine how much worse
it's going to be because the problems
that Greenspan created will pale in
comparison to the ones that Bernanke and
Yellin have created and so in this
bubble burst the fallouts gonna be much
bigger so where do you see the bubbles
within the market as a result right now
the bubbles are pretty much everywhere
they're in all financial assets so
they're in the stock market they're in
the bond market they're in the real
estate market they're in the US dollar
that could be the mother of all bubbles
and that might be the first one to pop
because in order to keep all the other
bubbles full of air the Fed has to keep
interest rates at zero I think they're
about to launch a fourth round of
quantitative easing everybody just
assumes right that the Fed is going to
raise rates that's not going to happen
under Obama probably will won't happen I
ponder anybody at least until there's a
currency crisis and remember about a
year
go janet yellen promised that she would
reduce the Fed's balance sheet back down
to about a trillion now of course it's
actually grown during that time it's
about four and a half trillion but the
markets are anticipating this tightening
I mean the Fed has never really reduced
its balance sheet it's just been a
one-way ticket and now Alan Greek now
Janet Yellen has promised to reduce it
not only is she not gonna you know
fulfill that promise
I think she's gonna double the balance
sheet again I think they have no
alternative if they want to prevent this
bubble from popping they gotta fill it
with more air and that's what they're
gonna do of course all of this is
destructive what the Fed should do is
let these bubbles pop they should raise
interest rates substantially and let the
chips fall where they may
we need to restructure this economy we
need to go from a borrowing spend
economy to a save and produce economy we
have to acknowledge that the debt is
unpayable just like Puerto Rico did it
has to be restructured we have to build
a recovery on a sound foundation we
can't just build it on a bigger bubble
than the last one the pop and no one
wants to take that risk politically I
mean do you see anyone even running for
president even the fiscal Hawks like
like Rand Paul for example or Ted Cruz
do you see them saying yeah what we
really need to do here is raise interest
rates so much that our debt service is
going to quadruple overnight well you
know they're not running for Fed share
so they're not going to talk about we're
saying a Federal Reserve is independent
and the executive branch Wow yeah but I
mean look that is not a winning campaign
message you know let's swallow this
bitter-tasting medicine because it'll
actually work you know with what the
voters want is snake oil they want
something that makes them feel good they
want
so if Rand wants to win he can't
necessarily lead with this message but I
support R and I think Rand really
understands the severity of these
problems and you know if it hits the fan
on his watch I feel much more
comfortable that we might actually do
something constructive about the
problems instead of trying to paper them
over with more stimulus it's only going
to make them worse what aren't we seeing
right so when yet again when you have a
bubble kind of thing at this time it's
different
you know we can we can survive
differently what are are we failing to
imagine right now as a
thing that could happen resulting in the
consequences of these actions well I
think it's a failure the same group of
people remember the people who think
that everything is great
right the people that think that the Fed
monetary policy has succeeded and that
the US economic recovery is legitimate
right these are the same people who had
no idea that there was a financial
crisis coming these are the people who
in 2008 thought everything was great
including Ben Bernanke or Janet Yellen
they didn't even know a recession was
coming even though one started you know
seven months earlier these guys were
still blind to the greatest financial
crisis since the Great Depression
it was around the corner and they
couldn't see it these are the same
people who were buying the dot-com
stocks and didn't realize that was a
bubble so the mainstream the investors
you know government central banks they
never see a crisis until after the fact
and then they go back and they say well
nobody could have possibly predicted
this you know this was a complete random
occurrence that had nothing to do with
our policy but of course that's never
the case the events of 2008 were highly
predictable to anybody who had a
rudimentary understanding of what was
going on but these guys were in denial
and they're in denial again so the
problem is they never understood the
cause of the the bubble that burst in oh
wait they didn't understand the feds
role in creating it so they don't
understand that the Fed is simply
exacerbated all the problems that
everybody believes they solve now bears
are always wrong until they're right so
in the interim yeah you know we've had
we've had stock market run up for a good
while now you know gold hasn't hit 5,000
yet as a result of various things are
you able to still make money playing
arbitrage on these on these bearish
predictions that haven't yet happened at
the way that you might have so yeah you
know I'd rather be wrong until I'm right
than right until I'm wrong because at
least there's some Donald Rumsfeld stuff
you're breaking on if you're right in
the long run you get to keep the money
if you're if you're wrong in the long
run you lose the money that you never
really had right you have paper profits
that vanish and I would rather wait
patiently wait for real profits to
materialize but
the problem with being right and being
early is that everybody else thinks
you're wrong and eventually some people
question it themselves right they think
maybe I'm the one that's wrong and
everybody else is right because it's
taking so long because you never know
exactly how long it's going to take for
the masses to wake up and realize that
they're wrong but you know history shows
that if you're patient and you know you
know that the fundamentals are and you
you know you stick to your guns in the
long run you're going to make money but
it doesn't mean that it's going to be
difficult in the short run because
you're going to be tested you know the
market generally makes it hard to do the
right thing and easy to do the wrong
thing right if you do the wrong thing if
you do what's popular chances are that
whatever you buy is gonna go up after
you buy it because more people are
making the same mistake as you and
they're bidding the price up and the
things that you know represent real
value the contrarian play you know you
might buy something and it might
continue to go down because people still
don't recognize the value that you see
the hard part is knowing when it's gonna
turn and I think that's almost
impossible I mean I guess the people who
can succeed spectacularly can time it
better and I don't necessarily know how
to time it but I can figure it out in
advance and I'm usually early but being
early is a lot better than being late
doesn't the US have some kind of success
curse at play here which is to say we
are a reserve currency we are a huge
thriving economy even when we're not
thriving particularly well we're this
thing this juggernaut and so you know we
can't be a Greece because we can print
our own money and we can have this
economic engine that's always going to
outpace whatever Greece doesn't any
given that period of time so is is that
hedge against the darkness that you see
or is that more like inflating the
ultimate final bubble yeah well the fact
that we can print our own money is
ultimately going to be our undoing it's
because we can print our own money that
the world has given us so much rope
which we've unfortunately hung ourselves
with or we're in the process of hanging
ourselves with it and you know the
vibrance that you talk about to the US
economy is merely a function of our
ability to keep borrowing money that we
can't repay to keep spending money to
buy stuff that we don't have the
Industrial
ability to produce so as the world
continues to vendor finance a customer
that can't possibly pay yes we can
continue to have what looks on the
surface to be this robust thriving
economy but all of that can change very
quickly when the perceptions of those
doing the lending change and the foreign
suppliers who are giving us all the
merchandise I mean think back to how
quickly the Soviet Union collapsed I
mean it was a huge monolith superpower
the world basically was America and the
Soviet Union it was like an empire and
it didn't take very long and all of a
sudden it wasn't there right it just
disintegrated and and so things change
quickly when they change and this idea
that America is this all-powerful nation
it's just an idea Dow it's based on a
myth at one time that was true we were a
mighty nation we did manufacture at the
goods that everybody wanted to buy right
we were the lowest cost producer of
manufacturing goods we had the most
economic freedom we had the lowest rates
of taxes the fewest regulations we were
a very free society was it a society
about government and about welfare and
wealth redistribution right when my
grandparents came to this country there
was no social security there's no
welfare there's no minimum wage there
was no income tax
there was no Medicare Medicaid Obamacare
there was nothing my grandparents came
here poor in search of freedom they
weren't looking for government help they
wanted the government to leave them
alone if they wanted government help
they would have stayed in Eastern Europe
but they came here for freedom and so we
built an incredible country based on
those principles we've abandoned those
principles and the wealth has been
abandoned as well now we're just an
illusion we have all this debt we have
to import all the things that we can't
make and we rely on the foolishness of
the rest of the world to continue to
finance it based on the legacy of what
America used to be speaking of our
creditors China which has gone through
all kinds of hell the last three weeks
and at least in the stock market here a
lot of people criticize the Chinese
economy for having its own system of
bubbles started like in in real estate
it's moved on to the stock market it's
frothing here and there as a bubble
watcher what do you see in China going
for
you can't help but create these types of
bubbles with the type of monetary policy
that China has but China has this
monetary policy because America has this
monetary policy they have made the
mistake of pegging their currency to the
dollar and so they import our monetary
policy they have to keep very interest
rates artificially low they have to keep
increasing their money supply to keep up
buying up the dollars to prevent their
currency from rising which is a mistake
a rising currency is what the Chinese
need that would mean that the Chinese
citizens would enjoy greater purchasing
power and they could buy all the things
that are currently being bought by
Americans I mean I think China would be
better off if when Chinese factories
produce stuff they distributed them in
Chinese stores to Chinese people instead
of paying to ship them across the
Pacific so that Americans can buy them
with money they borrowed from the
Chinese so but this monetary policy is
going to create property bubbles that's
going to create stop market bubbles the
solution is to take the air out of the
bubble by letting interest rates rise
letting their currency appreciate now of
course they've been resisting this even
though it's actually a good thing but
the country that has the most to lose
from the Chinese waking up is America
because we've been riding on their gravy
train but of course in the long run the
best thing that China can do is cut us
off it's like if you're you know hooked
on drugs you know your drug dealer would
do you a favor to stop supplying you
with drugs I mean you might not
appreciate it in the short run when
you're going through withdrawal but if
you actually you know kick the habit
then you know you would appreciate the
fact that the drug dealer cuts you off
right so long-term they should cut us
off this monetary drug so we can fix the
problems in our economy Peter Schiff no
more heroin for America thanks very much
for talking to Reason TV for reason TV I
am Matt Welch
[Music]